Alright, Pogchamp. You've probably seen
this dude's face when something hype or
surprising happens on stream. But who the
hell is this guy and where did he come
from? Well back in 2010 cross-counter TV
released a blooper reel featuring longtime
So Cal Street Fighter bros Ryan “Gootecks”
Gutierrez and Mike Ross. In the video,
this happened.
Youtubers loved Gootecks' unexpected
expression to the off-camera incident
but no labels managed to accurately
describe its dankness,
A year later, Gootecks and Ross released a
promo for a Mad Catz Fight Stick using
their goofy brand of humor and a random
game of pogs.
Gootecks would stomp Ross using an
ingenious technique.
The term PogChamp was born and
gradually attached itself to Gootecks's now iconic
face. "I remember I talked with Ryan
or I talked to Gootecks and I was like 'yo man
is that your face?' and he's like 'what are
you talking about.'" The fighting game
community fully embraced the meme and
in no time it spreads through the
internet via 4chan and Steam strangely
becoming the face of Team Fortress 2
raffles.
It wasn't long before PogChamp was added
to Twitch chat where today it is still
one of the site's most used emotes. But
PogChamp's influence has extended even
beyond gaming, becoming part of everyday
conversation. Find out your mom made
lasagna for dinner?
PogChamp. They're making a sequel to your
favorite movie? PogChamp. Finding out
you're not the father.
Definitely PogChamp. Gootecks responded
favorably to the internet community's
response to his face, harnessing the power
of PogChamp to build and develop his
personal brand.
While Gootecks has become renowned for
his amusing facial expressions over the
years, none have been able to generate
the community response and reactionary
memes of PogChamp.
"Man all the memes, man there's some talented people out there." And so ends this trip down meme-ory
lane.
I'm Josh Bury and that was PogChamp.